- [Interviewer] All right Jacqueline.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Jacqueline
where are you from originally,
where'd you grow up?
- [Jacqueline] I'm from California.
I'm from LA.
I grew up in South Central,
but I had the privilege of going to school
in Palos Verdes,
because of my family's background.
I was in between my grandpa
and my mom back and forth.
And my grandfather was a
retired LAPD for Parker Center,
a homicide detective.
And he was my everything
in the whole wide world.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your family,
you grew up with both of your parents?
- I don't know my father.
My mom had me when she was 12 years old.
- [Interviewer] Wow,
12.
- Yeah,
she had me when she was 12.
My mom was a hard worker.
She went to work every day
to support her four children.
Yeah.
And she met my stepfather
and everything went down the drain,
because he was a drug dealer.
And he sold every drug
that can be named in LA.
- [Interviewer] So how was
your childhood generally?
- My childhood when I was with my grandpa
it was very healthy,
but when I was at home it was terrible.
I hated it.
I'd rather be in the street than at home.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Mm hmm.
- The first trick I ever
turned was on Figueroa
to feed my brothers and sisters,
but I had to feed them because
my stepfather and my mom,
they were out selling drugs.
- [Interviewer] What age was that?
- Well my stepfather,
my mom would go behind my stepfather.
I don't know my mom,
she fell in love with a thug.
It was terrible,
but she wasn't brought up that way.
And then my mom allowed him
to sell me to his dope dealer
and you know,
and he used to molest me.
When my mom would go
to work he would make,
you know have me suck his dick
and promise me that he
wouldn't do it no more,
but he would every time my mom would work.
I hated him.
I didn't have a childhood.
You know,
I had to grow up early.
- [Interviewer] And life
was okay with your stepdad's
and stuff like that?
- My stepfather,
I dislike him because he
took something from me,
and he put a price on it.
He put a price on it.
He sold me to his dope dealer,
because his dope dealer wanted a virgin.
So he sold that.
He sold me to him.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- I was 10 years old.
Yeah.
The only person I could
talk to is my grandpa.
I told,
I told him everything.
Yeah.
Back in the eighties,
Hollywood used to be way out.
Yeah.
And it was like the glamorous thing that
I got caught up with this guy named Lucky,
because I was a runaway they
took me to a foster home.
And they put me in a foster home.
I met this girl there
and she took me to him
and was like,
he was handsome and one
day I wanted to go home
and him and his main girl
beat me up really bad,
because I wanted to go home
cause I miss my family.
Yeah.
And so a trick picked me up.
He took me home.
I told my grandpa what happened
what this pimp did to me.
And you know,
he got arrested.
He got,
he went to prison for 20 years for pimping
and pandering a minor.
But my grandpa,
he was my help,
cause nobody else would get involved.
But actually everyone
got word that I told.
I had no problems with pimps ever again.
So I've been to prison.
I've been to Chowchilla and CIW.
And this time I got clean.
I did one year in a program,
Assist the Alliance,
and I finally got,
I graduated and I was so happy,
because I had accomplished
something for myself.
It was awesome.
I was wanting to do that.
I wasn't forced to do it.
And I did it because I wanted to.
Cause I haven't had no
police contacts since 2010.
And I did that.
Yeah.
On my own.
- [Interviewer] What year were you
when you first started using crack?
- I started doing crack 19.
The day that they found
Tom Bradley's daughter
in the park and she was dead.
That was 1994 and shut the whole park
down because they found
Tom Bradley's daughter
in her trunk of her car dead.
- [Interviewer] And how old were you?
- I say I was about,
about 30,
maybe 32.
I don't remember.
(Watch beeping)
- [Interviewer] So you
didn't start using crack
until much later?
- No I was doing crystal meth.
- [Interviewer] Even
- Yeah
God dog it.
(Watch beeping stops)
Yeah that's the first drug I did.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- I'll say 17.
- [Interviewer] 17?
- Yeah.
I met Molly Jennifer,
her name,
and she took in all the runaways,
but she was awesome lady.
That was a safe haven for us.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You left home at what age?
- I say 11,
trash gingers took me in
and showed me the ropes
of the streets.
And I thank God that
someone taught me something.
But after the pimp I
didn't want to be bothered
with nothing.
I didn't,
I only had one pimp in my entire life.
My grandpa told me a pimp
doesn't like level prostitutes.
He just loves what she had given him,
once you're dead and gone,
he moves on to the next.
And that's a true statement.
He doesn't care about you,
he cares about the money.
Once you're dead and gone he moves on.
- [Interviewer] How
long were you with him?
- I say couple about a month,
but within that month I sold so much ass
that I was a young girl.
I used to be beautiful and you know,
your self esteem goes down.
I already had low self esteem anyway,
but you know this world can
make you feel this high,
and down here that really can do that,
because I never gang banged,
ever.
I think that's the most stupidest thing
in the whole wide world.
I guess that's something
I don't believe in.
That's not cool.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have kids of your own?
- [Jacqueline] I have four
Have beautiful children.
They're bilingual.
Their dad is,
Salvadorian.
- [Interviewer] Did you raise them?
- [Jacqueline] No.
- [Interviewer] Who raised them?
- [Jacqueline] I got
paid to have those kids.
Only kid that I had because I wanted to
is my youngest son,
his name is Autumn.
(Laughter)
He's beautiful.
That's the only kid I wanted.
The other three,
I got paid the have.
Yeah.
And they're in Minneapolis now.
- [Interviewer] With who?
- [Jacqueline] With their dad.
- [Interviewer] With their dad?
- [Jacqueline] Mhhmm.
- [Interviewer] And you're
living on skid row now?
- [Jacqueline] Yeah I
live like two blocks away,
but I'm leaving there,
because the person I stayed with,
I don't have sex with him,
so he wants me to leave.
I used to stay at the Lorane Hotel
and that hotel ruined and
took everything I owned,
but I lost everything.
I lost the phone that had my dead mom.
My mom is deceased now.
She got killed on Thanksgiving day of 84.
My mom and aunt and the
person that killed them,
did not do one day in jail.
That's when the Olympics came to LA.
- [Interviewer] How'd your mom,
- [Jacqueline] He shot my aunt three times
and shot my mom once.
This was in the newspaper.
It was in the San Diego
newspaper on Thanksgiving day.
And I miss my mom a lot,
but I lost a phone there
that had a picture of my mom.
She was 12 years old and
every time the phone rung,
I seen my mom and I that made my day,
every time that phone rung.
I've never been to my mom's
burial ground or anything.
I don't know where it's at.
It's here somewhere,
I don't know where it's at though.
Can I have some tissue?
Cause my nose is running.
- [Interviewer] So
you're not really crying.
- [Jacqueline] Yeah well I'm sniffling.
(laughter)
- When you lose your
mom you lost everything
that is important I think,
because there's a lot
of youngsters down here,
they have no respect their mom.
Accept your mom the way you are,
because she loves you.
She accepts them.
If I had one wish,
I wish I could be with my mom.
Just for,
she had you know,
she'd make a wish,
24 hours.
We'll hang out with one another.
My mom worked for the STCA.
So she taught me a lot about animals,
I love animals.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So even the
fact that your mom sold you out,
you still would love to see her.
- Yeah I love her.
Yeah.
I forgive her.
You know,
you have to forgive to be
blessed got to no matter what.
My mom made mistakes she wasn't perfect,
but she taught me to love animals.
I'm very good with animals.
I love animals of all nature.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So Jacqueline,
what are you doing for money now?
You still,
you still with guys?
- Well being honest,
when I need money,
I get SSI,
so I get almost $1000 a month,
but because of my crack habit it goes
and I need help with that.
I need a program,
I really do,
because I can't do it on my own.
I can't do a lower amount.
And I would love to do the
program and I would stay.
I need that or I'm going to
die out here in the streets.
I know,
I know that I'm going to die one day,
but I don't want to die real soon.
And stage four renal failure.
Yeah.
And this is what street's
done me or I did to myself.
Yeah,
yeah.
This is me stroking out.
It takes a toll on my kidneys.
That's probably why I'm
dropping weight so much,
but if I don't get somewhere and get help,
well once you go on
dialysis that's a done deal.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
your childhood traumas kind
of set you up for this lifestyle?
- I tried to commit suicide.
I set myself on fire.
I tried to take myself
out and it didn't work.
It didn't work.
That's the only reason why I get SSI,
because I tried to hurt myself.
And sometimes it's,
you know sometimes if you're dead,
you're better off.
I've seen a lot of people,
dead bodies that I never was exposed to.
But seeing these youngsters
beat up older people,
literally kill them.
It's like,
that's somebodies grandpa or father,
but they don't care.
They don't care.
So I try to just do me.
You know,
I do me.
I'm very kind to everybody.
I don't like fighting.
I have problem going on with myself.
I don't need to be and I,
I excuse myself from the problems.
I walk away,
because two rights don't make a wrong.
Those youngsters from Grape Street
they're really mean,
really mean.
Also they do,
they rob you and take your money.
And you know,
people work hard for what they have.
And if you don't respect your elders,
you're not going to have long life.
- [Interviewer] What was the first time
you were taken advantage of sexually?
- By my stepfather
- [Interviewer] Your stepdad?
At what age?
- I didn't even have tits yet.
I got pregnant by my
stepfather and you know
my mom took me to the
hospital of Fox Hills.
And I had an abortion
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- I don't remember,
but I was very young.
I think I was like 10,
maybe nine years old,
but I was pregnant by my stepfather.
I know.
I didn't know what was wrong,
but I know I kept throwing up.
And my mom had me checked by the,
you know the kid doctor that
she thought I was having sex
and everything.
And she said had,
you know she had checked me to
see was I having intercourse.
He's my,
I forget what kind of
doctor they call them,
a pediatrician.
Yeah the pediatrician told
my mom I was having sex.
- [Interviewer] What
was your mom's reaction
to finding out that her
husband was having sex
- She didn't believe me,
cause my grandpa had that man put in jail
and my mom told the cop
that it wasn't true.
Wasn't true.
When he got put up,
I mean,
he got free.
But I wouldn't lie to my
grandpa about nothing.
Nothing at all.
(blows nose)
So my grandpa was my everything,
because I can talk to him
and tell him everything.
And he didn't judge me.
He loved me no matter what.
And he would always tell me
that no matter what I love you.
Yeah.
He loved me.
The bad choices I made in life,
but he still cared,
and everything my grandpa tell me,
it come to pass,
everything.
Yeah,
Yeah I listened to my grandpa.
Yeah that's my guardian angel,
I think.
When I'm out here alone walking around.
Yeah that's my mom and my
grandpa are my guardian angel.
When my instincts talk,
I listen,
because all money's not good money.
And every car that glitter is not gold,
you know?
And a lot of girls had gotten in cars
on this street here and never came back.
So your instincts will
never lead you wrong.
And everyone has instinct.
Even if you're an animal.
You know animals could teach
you a lot about instinct.
Especially cats,
because they can see,
they have a spirit.
They can see things are not,
that a human can't see.
Animals have that instinct.
I've learned a lot from animals.
- [Interviewer] Do you,
do you have anybody in your life,
your family?
- I have family,
but my family,
well my brother he works at a,
in Malibu at a country,
a VIP only.
He's been their security for a long time.
I have found that and I
have family in Palm Springs,
but I want see my family so bad.
When I lost everything I own at Lorane,
all their numbers and everything I lost.
I want to go and just hug my family.
I'm tired of the streets,
because these streets don't love me.
- [Interviewer] Well, all
your years of working as a,
as a prostitute what has,
have terrible things happened to you?
- Yeah.
Yeah it has.
I've had men I do what they ask me to do,
and as I'm going out the door,
they come behind me and
grab me back in the room
and they,
one guy he just got a
prison and his friend,
it was terrible.
He told me he was gonna do me
like Jeffrey Dahmer did his victims.
And he did some bad
things to those people.
And I just went to sleep.
I didn't wake up till it was all over,
but they left me in the
hotel butt whole naked.
They took everything to a value of mine.
They treat me like shit.
I'm lucky I woke up though,
cause they could've
killed me and kept going.
Yeah.
I was out there when the
hill strangler was out.
That's my first time ever
running away from home.
When the hills strangler was out,
my mom worried so much for me,
because every time
somebody came on the news,
she prayed it wasn't me.
The hillside that's the first time,
yeah.
And that was like in the early eighties,
wasn't it?
And the hills,
they were in Hollywood and
they were picking up girls.
My mom prayed that it wasn't me when,
when they would announce,
yeah.
- [Interviewer] What do you think it is
that makes that lifestyle
okay for a woman?
- Well that lifestyle is not okay,
but it's the oldest profession there is.
And sex is sold every
day in different ways.
- [Interviewer] All right, Jacqueline.
Thank you so much for talking to me.
- Nice meeting you.
- [Interviewer] You too.
Thanks for coming in.